unas votaciones históricas hacia la
descentralización de chile el país
eligió por primera vez a los
gobernadores regionales y la alianza
unidad constituyente triunfó en nueve de
las 16 regiones del país
y en la región metropolitana se llevó la
victoria con claudio orrego
representante de la democracia cristiana
la potencialidad entre regiones
[Música]
por navidad
la unidad constituyente había perdido
las elecciones presidenciales de 2017 y
en las constituyentes de mayo pasado
alcanzó sólo 25 de 155 escaños
en esas mismas votaciones del partido
chile vamos de sebastián piñera alcanzó
35 escaños una derrota que se hizo más
contundente este domingo en el que solo
alcanzó la gobernación de araucanía
al igual que las votaciones
constituyentes de mayo estos comicios
regionales habían sido aplazados debido
a la pandemia de kobe 19 un asunto que
incidió en la participación este domingo
de las 13 millones de personas
convocadas sólo 2,5 millones se
presentaron a las urnas con este
panorama el país se prepara para las
primarias presidenciales de julio y la
primera vuelta en noviembre